en 1961 celui qui deviendra le des plus
grands danseurs de tous les temps le
russe rudolf nureyev passe à l'ouest et
du même coup il passe à l'histoire
il veut qu'on sait que tout le monde pas
juste
l'union soviétique je m'attriste
[Musique]
cette soif de liberté au nom de la danse
fait l'objet d'un film biographique sur
le danseur étoile en plus d'y jouer
l'acteur britannique ralph fiennes aussi
la réalisation de soudures ou deux nous
avons su nous avons demandé à deux
danseurs des grands ballets de visionner
le long métrage dans lequel le danseur
et chorégraphe russe oleg evenko
personnifie le frondeur nouriel les
scènes de danse sont véridiques parce
que c'est vraiment ça mais l'évolution
de cet art la technique a changé quand
il a fait les sols et les double tour
wafa dans la passé ce n'était pas comme
ça le réalisateur a volontairement
choisi de montrer sa vie de son enfance
à sa défection
mais les deux danseurs sont unanimes il
en aurait pris beaucoup plus de buts un
truc politique
bon c'est clair que c'était énorme à ce
moment là on voudrait pas choix de
parler de ça j'aurais bien aimé avoir vu
qu est-ce qui a fait après je vous vois
quand il danse avec le poids à paris et
est spécialement content et on nous le
liberia 2
d'après paris il a changé tous les
chorégraphies pour un laïc et qu'est-ce
qui est un but et l'icône de la danse a
une vie bien remplie jusqu'à sa mort des
suites du sida à 54 ans il a bousculé
les conventions du ballet le film nous
rieff demeure pertinent même s'il on
esquisse que son saut vers la liberté
ici julie jasmin boudreau radio canada
montréal
[Applaudissements]